for you now that Jack is kind of crossed
over to Superstar status I know he's got
a movie coming soon just did his first
uh headlining Arena tour yeah uh just
got nominated for best rap album of the
year yeah even though I don't think he
should have got nominated
personally but yeah I love the guy
um have you guys because I do feel like
when an artist hits that wave where
they're just like [__] out of here
do you guys keep your relationships as
solid as it always has been
I mean Jack is a solid human being so
because he kind of got to witness I kind
of feel like he was somehow like weirdly
wedged in between like the uzi
Generation Now thing yeah it was it it
was kind of unfair for him yeah you know
but like he kind of got to see and what
was dope is that he really you know he's
like
I feel like him
really standing by me during that meant
a lot you know what I'm saying and at a
time when like he could have just kind
of like
I I don't I don't want to say stay out
of it in a sense of that he was in it
but when the the the press or the way it
was being portrayed as if we were bad
guys jack really went out on a limb and
put his arm around me and was like yo
this is my guy you know what I'm saying
and I always tip my hat off to him for
that you know what I'm saying for
because he didn't have to do that he
could have he could have totally stayed
out of the way you know I don't even
know if you remember like there were
some pictures and then like you know
like Emma Uzi had a little back and
forth in between there I think I
remember that they had never even met
you know what I'm saying it was it was
basically just because I was in the
middle but
um so yeah to your point I mean he did
get to see that and you know obviously
when when you have artists like you know
you have these conversations early on in
their careers like yo you you know you
when you're a superstar like you know
people change or things happen and you
know Jack's just he's a solid guy you
know obviously at 25 you know where he
is with the type of success and this and
the stardom he's not the same kid he was
at 19 but you know he's he's a very
focused individual like you know he made
the decision years ago to to stop
drinking like you know to like
get in a workout regimen like he was
really really focused and you know I
just I just think outside of rap music
like
he's solid you know what I'm saying so
you know
they're they're all artists you know and
and
in our own ways me included like there's
always a certain level of narcissism I
feel like that comes along with being an
artist so you know there's times when
you you watch people being there be in
their mode their mode and you know it
comes with the territory you know it's
not something I'm like
I'm I've been doing this too long so I
get it but um but somebody like Jack I
will say you know I've watched I've
watched his growth and you know I'm
proud that like he still has maintained
this this level of of humility has he
started working on a new album yet yes
because I know I mean I feel like he had
such a wild year that like I kind of
feel like if I'm like Jack Harlow I'm
unplugging for like yeah a cool 90 days
for sure before the movie the album
first class I mean because he was he was
ever it was Jack Harlow season like he
was everywhere like you couldn't look
left or right without seeing Jack Harlow
so I would I mean to your point like
I would say these last couple months is
it's been a little more quiet right
outside of maybe like
a Super Bowl commercial or he wasn't
even in Arizona for the Super Bowl he
was not
he was he wasn't there because I was
like I was like oh I already know he's
about to do all the white clubs he
didn't go to Arizona for the Super Bowl
he wasn't an All-Star you know nobody
wants to go to Utah he was he was quiet
for the Grammys outside of going to the
Grammys right you know he's been in a
real work mode
um for the most part so you know he's
he's back in Louisville
um
work and and a space in an environment
that he's comfortable in and you know
he's he's got a lot of new music
um
give me the NBA young boy tape did you
have to go to Salt Lake City to link
with him or were you just sending over
[__] after like how's that because he's
kind of like a you know truthfully yeah
truthfully I got a call
on Tuesday or Wednesday
yo
I'm dropping a mixtape
Miss NBA youngboy calling you I want you
to host it
you know I got like two other tapes
coming out bro but
the week of
to the week of oh wow he was trying to
get out of that deal
he called me Tuesday or Wednesday I
think I did the tape if I if you call me
twos we dropped the tape Thursday night
I probably finished it Thursday
and we dropped it but like I'm not
saying no to an NBA young of course and
it's just like you know it was like I
had already the the Jeezy and the Snoop
and I and people that knew knew about
him right so I was like oh my god when I
come with a NBA young boy tape I'm gonna
[__] these [__] up like they're on one
day they're gonna be like yo drums on
some other drums it was like we were no
we was in New York I called you I called
you you did and I was like am I [__]
crazy or are you dropping three mixtapes
today I was like what the [__] is going
on
this [__] is crazy you just gotta grab
me bro chill let these [__]
breathe a little bit no chill not
letting nobody and it was Snoop Jeezy
and NBA young boys yeah that was crazy
Jesus Christ listen man I mean let's put
it in a perspective like
I've been what I've been DJing 30 years
I've been in the business
20 years two decades plus like I've had
a moment or moments where I was on fire
so now in 2021 22 23 I'm back on fire
like you can't turn it up yeah you got
to like you can't take that [__] for
granted and mind you even the years
before that like it's not like I haven't
been working it's not right you've been
on Jack hasn't been successful Uzi it
wasn't doing his thing or I didn't have
my Vegas residency or I was dropping
things here or there like it's not like
I have I I haven't been busy but to be
in this space right now at 45 with my
skin glowing like this yeah drinking a
gallon of water looking 21 like come on
man I'm not not playing you have never
stopped doing clubs never and you're in
a position where you don't need to do
nightclubs I don't so why do you still
do the club [__]
um
I don't like to leave any money on the
table
and
I it keeps me it keeps me fresh like I
like
I like to know like I like to as a DJ I
like to still feel like I know what's
going on you know like you still have
the fingers on the like pulse of the
shoe yeah because you kind of have to
have that in order to rock clubs
absolutely like you you have to it like
forces you to be yeah if you're not if
you're not in the clubs regularly or
know what's going on like yeah you can't
just go and not to the type of clubs
that we do or that I'm in like I'm
respectfully I'm not DJing for 45 year
olds like right I'm DJing for uh the
club age which is what like 21 to 30
right something or whatever so you know
to do that you know you gotta you gotta
stay in the mix and it's crazy because I
did get to a point like when I was like
30 37 38 like I came to Lake and I was
like bro like when I'm when I turned 40
bro I don't want to do clubs anymore
like I don't want to be that guy like I
don't want to be the old head in the
club and so there was a there was a
small period a small window where like
Lake wasn't booking me as much you know
what I mean like and we had
a bunch of other revenues of of you know
revenue streams coming in but I wasn't
really doing a lot outside of maybe like
my Vegas residency or um big [__] yeah
but I was because you'll do like you'll
pull up and do I mean we were talking
about flux R.I.P to flux in San Diego
but I mean you know I mean most of the
[__] I do is pretty you know it's it's
of a certain caliber for sure but
again like
you you know just to be in this position
and to get these opportunities like you
know it's a blessing like
the moment you take it for granted bro
the mo is the moment they take it away
from you you know what I mean and like
because you got to get it while you're
getting it because I don't know how long
it's Gonna Last and that's what I'm
saying like and I've it I've had a
blessed career that it's lasted this
long you know what I mean and like
you know but I I still feel Forever 21
like the store here it is you know
that's a bar